[Music]
the battle at the department of
mysteries feels just as intense behind
the scenes as with the incredible cgi in
the final cut weather was enhancing
flames during the battle of the weasleys
or adding magical effects to the battle
of hogwarts the harry potter team did it
all
because we are the high-tech
multi-million dollar production that we
are um the snake's double was a pole the
boxing glove tied to the end in the
goblet of fire we get one of the most
intense battles as harry and voldemort
face off at the end of the triwizard
tournament but behind the scenes the
battle looked pretty different
of course lights and effects were added
to show the casting of spells in their
duel but editing also had to be done on
rae finds's face to give him the
snake-like appearance of voldemort
harry's parents make their appearance as
well but while filming radcliffe didn't
actually have their support behind him
the two actors filmed their parts at a
different time and in a completely
different space
after the fact the editors managed to
tie it all together flawlessly
this emotional battle was just as
intense while filming as the completed
fight in the final cut we can totally
believe they were dodging spells and
trying to claim a victory without seeing
the lights of spells being cast the
tension in the room especially as
bellatrix takes serious out is very
evident i kept on doing like ping pong
sounds
during the battle of hogwarts voldemort
and harry make their way throughout the
castle battling in any room they can
find this epic staircase duel was no
different while behind the scenes they
were really on rubble covered steps the
rest of the scene looked much less
violent and magical without the cgi
their acting energy was high and the
harry potter and voldemort actors waved
their arms dueling for their lives in
the end as the two go head-to-head for
the last time we see an emotional but
much calmer scene than in the movie and
of course rafe finds doesn't dissolve
into the air after his defeat
the battle in the astronomy tower is
quiet and still without the cgi
the mood on the set while filming was
quite similar behind the scenes looks
just as dark as we feel seeing the final
cut of this heartbreaking moment and the
loss of dumbledore with the smallest
spell from snape yes
i'm
the half blood prince
the major battle of hogwarts in the
final film was just as chaotic behind
the scenes instead of cgi people huge
crowds of actors were on the set amid
the rubble while camera people ran
backwards through them capturing all the
action
the dumbledore and potter duo facing off
with voldemort is filled with fire on
screen but without the special effects
it looks like a bit of a different story
of course we couldn't get a real fiery
nagini or construct the entire ministry
set so cgi filled in all the details
hogwarts was in a seriously desperate
state while under attack from the fiery
quidditch stadium to the countless
spells being cast
none of which we see in the unedited
footage
cgi was key to amplify the gruesome
scene as more enemies stormed the castle
neville's fall was also made a reality
thanks to some excellent editing of the
shots captured on set
i went well
what could be better than one potter the
seven potters battling and racing away
to get harry and themselves into the
wizarding world safely involved a ton of
cgi
especially when it came to the speedy
motorcycle chase with hagrid
cgi was important to amplify all the
flames and environment for the wicked
battle at the weasleys but surprisingly
behind the scenes was nearly as
flame-filled the space did have actual
haze surrounding them alongside a few
fires to perform with but the vast field
was in fact a blue screen on set but
there's one condition
you must obey every command i give you
without question
dumbledore facing the cave infested
within fairy is dark and terrifying and
behind the scenes on a partially
constructed set michael gambin brought
the intensity acting pretty well on his
own the film crew included real fires
and moving lights to help create the
right effects
underwater filming was extremely intense
even without all the added effects
to help depict radcliffe's struggle a
rope was tied around him to pull him and
give the right sensation thank goodness
for the cgi used to erase the rope from
the image afterwards
of course the horcrux itself was edited
into the shot as well
what brings you here potter
i could ask you the same
on set filming the battle in the room of
requirement the actors were surrounded
by real flames climbing practical sets
and on occasion sporting safety
harnesses to pull off all the magic
behind the scenes we don't see the fire
snake whipping through the piles of
furniture either but the performers
definitely make us believe it's there
while a large space was built to film
the scene much of the room of
requirement is actually completely cgi
from the pillars to the floors
the hungarian horntail
facing off with the hungarian horntail
was no small feat and radcliffe brought
it with his performance in the first
task of the tri-wizard tournament the
cgi dragons movements were based on that
of a hawk this and the animation of the
creature were digitally rendered and
added to the final image luckily on set
there were no real dementors but it did
mean daniel radcliffe had to be hooked
up to a rig that could maneuver and lift
him while the actor pretended to be
choked
when editing time came around the
intricate work began and the digitally
rendered dementors took their place
harry talks asleep
one last visit to the chamber of secrets
to destroy a horcrux but for this very
wet scene a strategically set up green
screen acted as the base for when ron
and hermione used the power of a
basilisk fang a combination of cgi waves
bursting up around them and the real
wave of water soaking the actors made
for an epic scene
we saw maggie smith come to life as she
exerted the most graceful power facing
off with and making a fool of snape in
the midst of the war at hogwarts
cgi was responsible for the effects of
the spells but smith was responsible for
the fierce power
harry you do realize what tree this is
hermione and terry versus the whomping
willow wouldn't have been possible
without the added special effects that
brought the tree to life and made it a
force to be reckoned with when the scene
got a bit more intense watson wound up
swinging around on a prop branch while
radcliffe tried to avoid being hit by
what would eventually be the tree's
trunk the actual set the burning of
hagrid's home was filled on wasn't too
different from what we see in the final
film aside from some effects to augment
the dark and gloomy scene the fact that
there's an actual explosion taking place
on set adds a major wow factor to this
heartbreaking scene as bellatrix
celebrates all the havoc she's caused
fred i've been thinking exactly the same
thing
fred and george really stick it to
umbridge with a literally explosive exit
from hogwarts wreaking complete havoc
throughout the dining hall the twins
filmed their flying separately on a
broom in a green screen setting enabling
the editors to add their images to the
chaos of the dining hall
we know by now it's not just people or
animals that can be dangerous
plants can be fierce in the world of
harry potter and the maze didn't go easy
on cedric diggory instead of vines
wrapped around him robert pattinson was
tied up in a rope and pulled to mimic
the way the ferocious plant drags and
traps him
for a moment though i thought you were
going to let it get me
in the moment so did i
while the cgi in the movies is fantastic
behind the scenes does look just as
impressive sometimes because of how much
was built for the actors to film on and
how many real effects like raging fire
were actually carried out
which battle do you think looked most
interesting without the added effects